Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But hi again everybody Thank you so much for joining us today,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Welcome to the RStudio,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Enterprise Community meetup i'm Rachel calling in from Boston today I will be heading to nashville for my birthday i'm super excited heading there later today,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But i'm joined by my colleague Lou who's going to be helping out in the chat event, if anybody has questions there, but if you've just joined now feel free to introduce yourselves through the chat window to and say hello, maybe where you're calling in from,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I do want to also make note that if you want to turn on live transcription during the meetup you can do so as well in the zoom bar below you just press, the more button,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But to go through,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): brief agenda,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): We will go through some short introductions of this meetup group and Kelly will introduce us to tips for navigating internal processes and advocating for data science infrastructure,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Also, sharing her own experience in doing so, so hopefully that will be able to help a few of you also do the same,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): we're doing things a little bit differently here today, so after kelly's presentation will stop the recording and would love to open it up to discussion with everyone here to hear what you're facing and how we can all help each other, too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So for anyone joining this group, for the first time, a special welcome to you, this is a friendly and open meetup environment for teams to share the work they're doing within their organizations,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): teach lessons learn network with each other and really just allow us to all learn from each other, so thank you all so much for making this a welcoming community,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): We really want to create spaces, where everybody can participate, and we can hear from everyone say like to reiterate that that would really love to hear from everyone, no matter your level of experience or the industry that you work in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So for cautions for the meetup you can always ask questions in the zoom chat or raise your hand to ask live, but we also have a slideshow link that you can use, so you can ask questions anonymously as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And if you ever have suggestions or general feedback, please let me know i'll share a few links in the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But if you do find this format helpful today we'd love to have more champion chats so i'll start by saying the third Monday of every month we will try,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): to stick to that, but i'll share more info when I put the recording up as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But with all of that Thank you again so much for joining us i'd love to turn it over to our speaker today Kelly o'brian Kelly is a product manager here at RStudio and is interested in configuration and workflow management with a passion for our and data science,
kelly obriant: Thank you kyle angel yeah i'm honored to kick off the first champions chat here and I just have a couple of slides,
kelly obriant: together to hopefully spark some discussion, later on, I apologize up top that my voice is a little,
kelly obriant: Terrible because I did three days of hard gravel riding over the weekend, as a fun vacation and,
kelly obriant: suffering now but happy to be here talking about,
kelly obriant: analytic infrastructure, which I have been passionate about for a long time before I was a product manager here at RStudio,
kelly obriant: I worked on the solutions engineering team that's how I joined RStudio, and I say you have a I think a couple solutions engineers on the call Gagan I saw on the call and,
kelly obriant: And we've got Nick from customer success worked with him for a long time here at RStudio and Rachael, of course, our ultimate champion of champions, and so happy to to share some of the experience that i've gained here in RStudio and that brought me to RStudio actually so,
kelly obriant: And I want to talk a little bit about what advocating for analytic infrastructure sort of looks like to me, and in my past lives,
kelly obriant: And I want to talk about what it is and why it matters and ideas for identifying leverage points for yourself,
kelly obriant: so that you can be a better advocate for your own workflows internally at your own organizations and so that you know how to interact with the Community and ask for the support that you need from us and from the community at large, so,
kelly obriant: Before I get into that I want to start by acknowledging or identifying like where you are now on the spectrum inside of your own organization and and this this slide is it can be a little bit depressing, so I promise it will like,
kelly obriant: we'll have some more activism from here, but everybody starts inside of an organization that's like at a different stage in its,
kelly obriant: Like organizational culture, its growth it's points and and there you know it's important to to identify where you are on the spectrum of,
kelly obriant: organizational culture topology because you need to know what you're sort of working against when it comes to doing advocacy and,
kelly obriant: Asking for change inside of your own organization so on the right hand side you have your generative performance oriented,
kelly obriant: organizations, this is the idea like if you are in this type of organization like hopefully you feel really supported, and you can ask for what you need, and you can build business cases to support those asks and,
kelly obriant: Every everybody is cooperating building bridges between teams is highly encouraged, you can take risks and feel supported in that,
kelly obriant: area, you can fail and then ask questions about what happened, and you are through all of that process sort of taking care of,
kelly obriant: And the Center you've got your ruling oriented organizations, these are more bureaucratic and there's some cooperation and not like super highly motivated cooperation,
kelly obriant: you're sort of like ignored or like bridges or tolerated but not encouraged also like,
kelly obriant: novel Problem Solving can work over time, but you have to work really hard at it, maybe you have to build some new rules on the way or show why the old rules are outdated and it's a lot of work to get things done on the left hand side effects or pathological or,
kelly obriant: Just,
kelly obriant: A funny word,
kelly obriant: But i've definitely been a part of these places where they are entirely power Oriente there's very little cooperation you don't want to stick your head up for,
kelly obriant: offering these solutions because you'll be shot down everybody is shirking their responsibilities, everybody is scapegoating and all novel ideas are crushed, and this is a real soul sucking place to be at, and if you are in this place, like, I am very sorry,
kelly obriant: I hope that you'll find some support within this group as well, because you know, like,
kelly obriant: That you can find yourself inside of these places and teams and and it's really unfortunate and we want to help you understand and see from the outside,
kelly obriant: That it it's really almost impossible to make change and advocate for yourself if you are truly inside of a pathological organization and,
kelly obriant: We want to see you move towards a healthier spaces, where you can find more cooperation and support so,
kelly obriant: I just lay this out at the beginning of every time I give sort of one of these talks, because I know everybody's coming from different types of organizations and spaces,
kelly obriant: And, and I don't want to paint this as like a super rosy picture, where like you can do everything, because sometimes there are just forces at play that are really difficult to navigate and move against and and so,
kelly obriant: yeah i'll leave it at that and will will will now go into the more optimism side of the story side, I hope that,
kelly obriant: You know, as you're looking at yourself in this picture you're finding yourself more on the right hand and the left hand side, but if you are more on the left hand side and then just know that this is a safe space we're here to talk about it,
kelly obriant: So what is elastic infrastructure, I defined it is all the how, where and was what that goes into doing your daily data science work, this is sort of a picture of a bunch of stuff that could,
kelly obriant: involve portions of your analytic infrastructure environment ignore the red line in the box in the Center it's,
kelly obriant: Just sort of in there from a different diagram but you've got,
kelly obriant: data sources you've got processes you've got artifacts that you're building you're deploying managing scaling those artifacts that you've built off of processes that have both data sources,
kelly obriant: And you could be integrating with other things like bi databases reporting systems workflows underneath you've got like security channel access validation,
kelly obriant: And then other things programming languages packages and dependencies and operating systems, all of these things plan to how you do your daily to do science for work,
kelly obriant: And all of these things look different in different organizations will look different for you like we use the terms like levels of sophistication but even that is like a little bit,
kelly obriant: hard to put into a box like when I have pulled previously groups of our users about what their definition of production is here are some like the,
kelly obriant: varied answers i've gotten to that question production could be doing things at scale, it could be things that are customer or user facing,
kelly obriant: could be like something as technical as like production is a service level agreement, they are for mission critical operations, it could just be a set of environment requirements like areas where validated applications are deployed in a lockdown way,
kelly obriant: It could be that production means just documenting processes doing due diligence around testing and monitoring my favorite answers in the middle somebody just wrote a single word response credibility,
kelly obriant: And so you can see there's like all of these different things that go into production production to me is like how you define the environment across the board, from,
kelly obriant: Even starting with development, all the way to whatever it ends up being that you deliver and and those environments that you're doing your work inside of,
kelly obriant: And I don't I don't want people to get caught up in the hype machine here like this is a screenshot of me googling devops tools and like,
kelly obriant: crazy sets like like tools that you could employ to build out these environments and when I say like that i'm not going to provide,
kelly obriant: Any solutions here like RStudio sells products that you can build environments completely on open source tools like we're not here to give you any like,
kelly obriant: easy answers even because there are none, there is no standard architecture, because you know the types of problems that you're trying to solve, and so you need to understand like,
kelly obriant: What tools makes sense for you and your own environment and and there's also no perfect deployment pipeline, everything is and should be evolving over time,
kelly obriant: Even so, you you don't even get to rest on your laurels, the point you should always be evaluating your processes and determining whether you can can make them better,
kelly obriant: These are all lessons i've learned from the world of devops, and I say devops I don't mean like the tools that you find when you Google what is devops I mean like the philosophy of devops teams working together,
kelly obriant: to accomplish goals inside of an organization,
kelly obriant: And one of the really interesting think,
kelly obriant: tactical metrics that spoke to me when I did a deep dive on devops was the idea of code deployment lead time,
kelly obriant: And this is this is something that i've i've never bothered trying to measure my own life but I realized that I was and,
kelly obriant: As I have been on different teams trying to accomplish goals and projects almost subconsciously measuring like,
kelly obriant: How long does it take us to accomplish this thing How long does it take us from going from raw materials point A to some kind of finished product, and when I feel like that time is like crowing or it's taking too long, it starts to great on me like in my heart in my core be,
kelly obriant: It eats away at me and that's what,
kelly obriant: I think makes me a natural,
kelly obriant: analytic administrator makes me a champion because I,
kelly obriant: Am very bothered by these types of problems so both of these questions are really interesting to ask yourself if you haven't like How long does it take you to get some raw materials to a finished product,
kelly obriant: Is that something you measure or is it something that you just into it and eats away at you, and how many teams, do you have to traverse to make real impact,
kelly obriant: With the product of your that's another really interesting one, it may or may not be relevant to you, but also very relevant to the world of devops philosophy,
kelly obriant: Why does this matter,
kelly obriant: Your analytic infrastructure is what enables you or teams to deliver value through decreasing that code deployment lead time and it also dominates how your daily work is performed that these are like pretty obvious,
kelly obriant: Lessons I think,
kelly obriant: This author Gene Kim has written a number of really influential books in the devops space, two of which are novels about it, and what is called the phoenix phoenix project and one is the unicorn project and,
kelly obriant: i've enjoyed both of them, if you want to read a really corny novel about it in Dev OPS I highly recommend it,
kelly obriant: And this quote is from him and improving daily work is even more important than doing daily work, and so,
kelly obriant: If you don't have the tools, you need to accomplish the data science daily for that doing if you are doing things in spreadsheets that take days, instead of what you could automate in minutes or even seconds,
kelly obriant: That it's it's affecting you it's affecting your team it's affecting your organization's bottom line, and so, taking the time and energy to advocate for better processes,
kelly obriant: is in fact more important in those cases and doing the daily work of those tasks and moving our spreadsheets around from place to place let's just make sure, but it's something for my real life I have spent,
kelly obriant: days and days and hours and hours doing things inside of spreadsheets that could be automated and it's really interesting because I feel like,
kelly obriant: I have a really high tolerance actually for doing that sort of stuff, even though I said, like it does crush my soul,
kelly obriant: At a certain point there's another you know, like, I find it very meditative to work inside of spreadsheets I don't have anything you can spreadsheets fit,
kelly obriant: But there is like also this power and like real importance to advocating for process automation and getting to the point where you can see,
kelly obriant: and make the business case for the importance of automating basic processes,
kelly obriant: And, and so i've got i've had a lot of success in my own career doing that sort of advocacy and work,
kelly obriant: That it does it does sometimes come at the cost of then realizing the type of organization that you're a part of this gene Kim in the unicorn project really you know, like this, these stories are both the same both the phoenix project and the unicorn project they're both like like,
kelly obriant: Very fun because they start inside of organizations that are somewhere between bureaucratic and a little bit pathological and so,
kelly obriant: And then they they build out from that you watch these characters like call their way back out of these organizations and like build a better future for themselves, and so I read being a current project is probably never came out in 2020 or 2019,
kelly obriant: This this captures like this really visceral feeling that i'm talking about in this scene, the main character maxine is a developer and she's trying to improve how development work is done,
kelly obriant: On her project in this like crucial critical way, but everything she tries fails and, like every bit of progress progress, she bakes seems impossible and she's like at her wits end and i'll do a dramatic reading she buries her head in her hands and silently screams done,
kelly obriant: If you are looking for some sort of like catharsis,
kelly obriant: I highly recommend this book,
kelly obriant: And the phoenix phoenix is the most important project in the company they've spent 20 million over three years, and yet here she is trying to help,
kelly obriant: And they won't spend $505,000 on more disk space and now she won't get a development, environment, for five months if you ever felt like you have been in the scenario then read this book and feel better,
kelly obriant: But also come to this group, because this is, who we all are we're we're this type of person we've experienced this type of pain and Nathan, Stephen siloed bossier at RStudio, who is now since moved on to bigger, better roles, maybe we're so sad to see him go but,
kelly obriant: He,
kelly obriant: wrote very eloquently about analytic administration and the type of role that this person at the time we call it the our admin inhabit it now or more,
kelly obriant: More language, inclusive, we can we can open it up to R and Python admins or data science happens in general but it's a data scientist who,
kelly obriant: onboard new tools to play solutions supports existing standards works closely with it to maintain upgrade and scale analytic environments influences other organization others in the organization to be more effective and who is passionate about making,
kelly obriant: Data science a legitimate analytic standard within the organization,
kelly obriant: I really like this,
kelly obriant: This definition of who we are, in the space, because it feels very powerful and it really spoke to me, this is one of the reasons this this type of of,
kelly obriant: Thought leadership that Nathan was was writing at the time as one of the reasons why I joined RStudio the solutions and sharing group,
kelly obriant: Because I felt like a real sense of community here and that's what I hope that we can chat about today so,
kelly obriant: i'll open it up to the group from here, but I wanted to leave this is sort of like, here are some of the challenges that I see for elliptic administrators in this space and I,
kelly obriant: Typically break them out in different toxin into organizational challenges and technical challenges on the organizational side like we've talked about or been talking about there's like,
kelly obriant: The question of credibility and legitimacy,
kelly obriant: Do you have that are you able to advocate inside your organization from a credible and legitimate place do you have the right leverage points or business cases built out,
kelly obriant: To support you and the cases that you're trying to build and asking for the tools that you need,
kelly obriant: Do you have the right relationships have you built out a functional working relationship with a ti and how do you go about doing that,
kelly obriant: And then on the technical side are there places where you feel as an analytic admin or you don't even feel like you're ready to take on the mantle of that title yet,
kelly obriant: Maybe you need some more technical skills experience education or exposure in order to get to that level and so across these topics, especially I would love to know how we could support each other as,
kelly obriant: A Community RStudio business can support you as well, and I think I love this site, especially the building a business case section of the champions site, if you haven't checked it out at RStudio COM slash champion,
kelly obriant: I know Rachel had a big hand in putting this together, as well as i'm sure a bunch of other people and share some some folks on this calls customers,
kelly obriant: who have helped us out in a huge way in pulling this information together the section in particular on how to build a business case and a playbook for that,
kelly obriant: is really powerful, so I recommend starting here, especially if you're not sure where to get started or ideas for how to get conversations rolling like you need to first and foremost come to the table with,
kelly obriant: Some sort of asked some sort of plan and, and this is a really great framework for thinking about how to start building that, so I will stop talking sorry once I get role, and I just keep going,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): That was great Thank you so much,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): We were saying in the chat when you were showing the image from the plumber heck sticker I always equate that to you because I first saw that hex image from at a woman and data science conference and it's when I met you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Was funny to see it there too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And just a reminder to everyone that you can ask questions on slide oh as well if you wanted to ask anything anonymously, but I am going to stop the recording now just so that everybody can feel free to just jump in to the conversation as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But for people watching the recording Thank you as well we'd love to have more of these champion chats as well, so i'm going to say the third Monday of every month at 12 Eastern time let's keep these going but i'll put more information, the recording to let me stop that,